foreign
foreign
we're joined here with a subscriber
named Dom
who just recently accepted Islam so now
I'm like bro how are you doing
brother I'm good bro I'll handle that
I'm good
do you want to tell the viewers a little
bit about your story bro I want to jump
right into it inshallah and yeah how did
you find our Channel
so I found the channel
um I actually you guys came up with my
recommended like a good amount of times
before but I never really watched any of
your videos
um I was like tuning into a lot of like
sneak on young Don and I came across you
guys in that one video where you guys uh
you guys all were in that one one chat
on Discord
when young Don came in and then I think
check with man and uh yeah yeah so that
was when like I actually came across you
guys for real
uh I saw that whole conversation happen
and then uh yeah I just I started
getting into your videos and everything
you know what's weird bro we had a
subscriber I think you even dm'd us
about a month ago his name was Dom just
like you Dominic and he accepted Islam
bro
yeah yeah you uh so so that's a a very
significant part of the story
okay let's go into the Bronx please bro
please
yeah all right so um
so yeah I I guess my story is um I was
born here in Canada you know my my mom
is Filipino my dad's from Nigeria
um they're both Christian and uh I grew
up in uh you know in a Catholic
environment Catholic School
um I'm sorry yeah I'm smiling bro
because Filipinos and Nigerians are
super Christian bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah super freaky [ __ ] yes so so you
know like
I I was brought up in a very like
Christian environment you know
um
I went to Catholic School
um you know we learned about Catholicism
and you know learn a lot about Jesus
a lot of a lot of like what we do or
what at least a lot of like what I did
it would come behind like you know what
would Jesus do or whatever and um
yeah so
I I was brought up as a cushion and um
you know throughout Elementary School
like I was um
I was like I was like quite a pushover
you know like
I would um
like let a lot of a lot of things like
you know happen to me or whatever but
like not say anything about it
um
I guess as an example like I remember
during lunch time like there's this one
guy in my class who would like um
like when the bell rings for snack time
or whatever like you grab my lunch
before I even get a chance to get my
lunch and like for me I was just I'd
always like end up making an excuse for
it like uh you know like um he probably
didn't have one himself or whatever and
like
you know so
I uh
going into like High School
I um
a lot of my friends were telling me yo
like you can't and like continue to be a
pushover whatever whatever like you're
you're gonna get like destroyed if you
go into High School
um and I was like
you know I kind of felt that because I
was getting taken advantage of a lot or
whatever whatever so
I'm I kind of like made a switch like
it was like um
I I changed I changed my personality
like like a good amount
um not not in like a proper direction so
I uh you know Channel like I tried to
put on like a facade you know I tried to
uh be very um
you know I I oriented myself to certain
things
um and
yeah you know like I was trying to be
like you know big man like cool guy
whatever whatever like try really hard
to to like make sure I appear a certain
way and all this stuff whatever
uh and so like you know during High
School
um
you know there's a lot of a lot of like
parties going on whatever and I I was
you know devoting myself to Christianity
a lot of the time like
um even like during the times of these
parties or whatever like sometimes I
would if the party started at eight like
I would go at eight and then there's
like a youth group at my church at like
nine so like I'd leave prior to go to
youth group and not like not going to
not go to the rest of the party whatever
and um so you know like I was I was
trying to like really like still stay
devout to Christianity but like I um
I was I was getting into certain things
or whatever and uh so
there was this one time in high school
where there's this party that everybody
was going to and you know because I I
really wanted to
you know put myself out there and like
you know present myself in a certain way
like I really wanted to go to this party
um but but at this time my mom she was
uh she was battling cancer
and um you know she was she was going
through chemo and stuff and um
you know like she was you know she was
sick so
I was I really wanted to go to this
party and my my parents were like
like nah like you gotta stay you gotta
stay home and like
this is like maybe like grade nine or
something I was like 14 and I I got I
got mad like I was like
I was like you know like um all my
friends are going to this party like
whatever whatever
um how come I'm not getting to go yada
yada
um and
I got in like a a little like argument
with my parents
and then after after that argument like
I I felt like extremely guilty
like that was like one of the first
times where I realized like yo like
a lot of um
a lot of these things that I'm feeling a
lot of this this desire to like you know
gather this attention or whatever or
like to to you know go and present
myself in a certain way like you know
this very like egotistic like mentality
like like what am I doing like you know
I'm I'm losing the bigger picture you
know like my mom is sick you know like
I'm
like what am I I'm the first born in my
family like I I I gotta like
I gotta fulfill that role whatever
whatever so like I'm I'm like
trying to
I I felt really guilty at the time
because
I wasn't doing what I should have been
doing I was I was falling into like all
these um all these like desires that
weren't
that weren't helping me like
I was losing I was losing the bigger
picture essentially like you know I had
to like really like do what I could to
like
I guess take care of my mom and stuff so
so at that time
um
there was like another another switch uh
in my head where like
I I was like hyper aware of
all these all these thoughts like I
started to become like Super Hyper aware
of like
you know the way I I look or whatever or
like
trying to avoid those thoughts or
whatever like I I would
try to like essentially like destroy
like my ego or whatever
and uh like push push aside all these
all these thoughts of um
you know thinking of myself in a certain
way so
um
so okay I'll mention this this story
it's packaged I guess I could package it
in like three parts you know this this
part right now of you know me being a
Christian
and then eventually I like you know
entered this like this
um state of like you know atheism
um
and um
and you know alhamdulillah like a Muslim
now you know like and I'm I'll get to
that part I'll get to that point when
you when you see the second part not to
jump to a head but just to tease the
viewers do you mean atheist atheists or
just agnostic and Confused
I guess
then agnostic uh
in that in that area like there was a
small part of atheism and then I guess
it kind of transitioned into like you
know just a little bit confused or
whatever okay but sounds good
yeah so um
yeah you know so like at that time I was
really like
down and like really really like not
trying to allow my ego to like
uh fall into these these you know
desires of wanting to be something
whatever
um but I I started to feel like it
started turning into um like a lot of
like like negative talk about myself you
know like a lot of like me trying to
avoid these things by like like putting
myself down or whatever
and um
eventually like
uh around like grade 11 like
I just I just started like
um going into this this route of uh like
like depression like I I all of like my
flaws just I just became like Super
Hyper like hyper aware of all my flaws
um you know there was I I was praying a
lot at the time and like I was
um
you know trying to
avoid certain Sims and
like
I I just I just like went down this
route of like
it's that I don't know it was just it
was a very depressing route
and like I I reached a point where it
was like man I don't know what to do I
started
um
you know I essentially started to
develop like a nihilistic mentality and
uh and there was a point where like you
know like I was so far in that like you
know I just I just thought man like
what's the point of like me being here
you know like what's the point of like
any of this
um you know and and that was like a
point where I really was like you know
like you know like off myself or
whatever and like it was it was very it
was very dark it was a very dark time
um
and so like
at that time to I guess in retrospect
like it was a it was almost like an
attempt to like relieve myself of that
guilt but like I like maybe
subconsciously but at that time
um
I I was also learning world religion at
the time and
I guess I
I decided to like take myself
um away from from religion
because I
I started to develop this nihilistic
mentality that like you know
why is there so much like corruption in
this world and why is there so many
people that like you know they do so
much good and um and like you know they
don't get anything for it or whatever or
at least like that that's what my mind
was thinking at the time like uh you
know I'm trying really hard to to be a
good person I'm trying really hard to
you know devote myself to to
Christianity and and you know do these
good things and you know I'm just
getting stepped on and you know there's
so many people that like you know
they're they're doing this down in the
third and then they get this and it
started to lead me to the path of like
you know looking at other people and
like
all these people you know that they they
you know devote themselves more than I
do and they try so hard and then you
know they end up getting you know
crushed or whatever and then there's
people that like you know they have such
evil in their hearts and then they end
up getting like all these other things
and um
so that though that train of thought
kind of led me to you know to nihilism
and I uh I'm like okay like none of this
matters like you know you know stuff for
a lot like I took myself like away from
God you know like out I like I said okay
like I don't I don't believe in prayer
anymore like it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense to me whatever
whatever
um
and so that that's where I entered like
my that that atheism you know I I I'm
like okay it doesn't make sense for for
you know this to exist it doesn't make
sense for this exists like whatever
whatever
um
and none of this really matters
and so
at the time like yeah I mentioned that
like we were studying world religion in
high school and
I started to learn about like all these
other religions I started to learn about
you know like Buddhism and taoism and
and all these other religions and and a
little bit more about Christianity and I
started to learn about Islam
and uh you know like we learned about
the five pillars of Islam and we learned
about this about Islam and you know it
was very interesting so
but um
I I took myself away from religion
because I was learning these things it
was with the intent of like
eventually bringing myself back or
hoping to bring myself back
to religion
um because I did see that there was like
there was truth in it there was there
was there was there were truths that I
was trying to look for
um
and so at that point
I thought okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a step back from Christianity
I I stopped you know calling myself a
Christian
but I want to learn you know I want to
learn about what's going on I want to
learn
I wanna I wanna Orient myself towards
like what is true you know like what is
what is true
and so
um yeah I
started um I started University after
that
um I started like learning about other
religions and like you know really
really getting into other religions
um I was really
um
I I like the teachings of Buddhism and
end taoism and uh I was learning about
Islam a little bit and you know come
University like a lot of my friends you
know ended up being Muslim and so like a
lot of my friends uh around me you know
they would you know tell me this tell me
that about Islam
and like I you know I saw I saw that
there was you know things that really
that they they made sense to me at the
time and um
and because I wasn't I took myself away
from religion I thought like
you know this this might be
something that that that makes sense but
with that with that like that atheism or
that
nihilism in my heart like
I was kind of like rejecting a lot you
know
um
and so
I was resonating with a lot of like the
Buddhist teachings at the time a lot of
the teachings of taoism
um and I was I was getting a lot into it
um you know come University like I meet
so this girl I met and uh you know she's
she's Palestinian she's Muslim this was
six years ago
um and you know I
we you know started to talk and and
you know we we both kind of saw each
other as like you know a fit to you know
to be together you know to be to get
married or whatever
um and I knew she was Muslim and I like
you know my intention was you know to
to get married essentially
and like
I at the time I was thinking okay like I
don't I don't I'm not really subscribing
to any religion I don't mind I don't I
don't mind like you know coming to Islam
but I
I have to know I have to learn more
about it
so
um yeah I I started to learn more about
Islam
um
my friends gave me the Quran you know
I've been watching a lot of videos
whatever whatever
but
I was there was there was these things
that were like
having me reject it
um and
I
I was watching a lot of videos you know
I was trying to like understand Islam
but I was trying to understand it
through
um watching debates or whatever or
watching this video in that video and so
I watched a lot of like debates between
you know Muslims and atheists Muslim and
Christian and then like you know
religion whatever whatever uh a lot
watch a lot of like Muhammad hijab and
um you know like hamza's artists and um
uh all these other guys you know them
debating with the you know these atheist
characters and like you know like
um yeah and
a part of me was like
a part of me was
a lot of the time when I would hear
these these um these debates I was a lot
of time on the side of the atheist
and
it
it
because
they read you know the whoever was
debating on the Muslim side would be
talking about God
uh in a certain way and and like I was
like kind of rejecting it because you
know I didn't believe in that like I I I
um I was like
nah like how can you say that like that
doesn't really make sense
um
but eventually I I started to
understand that
is an initial there is like a one you
know there is there's a first there's
you know I started understanding these
arguments about like these these logical
arguments about like you know the first
mover uh you know the the intelligent
design argument
you know like
like recently I came across a video
where he like explained it really well
like uh something along the lines of
like you know if I wanna if I want to
shoot like Angel and
I want to shoot them but I have to get
you know your permission
but then you have to get someone else's
permission
and then that person has to get someone
else's permission to shoot then
essentially the shot never happens if
that's an infinite if that continues to
happen so
there has to be like a first before
anything happens
and so like with those like with those
like logical arguments is when like I
started to
God again but
my my belief in God was not
um
it it was just like okay I believe in
like a first and then so I started
delving into these uh these Eastern
philosophical practices you know like I
know like on how like
um
I came across a good amount of your
videos back in the day too you know like
um you know and you know it talks about
like you know spirituality whatever
whatever
and like
I was delving into these Eastern
philosophical practices and
um getting into meditation and all this
stuff and
like that that was making sense for me
and like you know these these things
about like you know universe and like
um
these these laws of the universe and you
know the secret and whatever whatever
um Law of Attraction Law of Attraction
and yeah you know so I started I started
like
getting into that into those things and
like you know learning them and stuff
and
those those things are resonating with
me like at the time at the time
and so
I'll
trying to simultaneously learn about all
these religions at the same time I was I
was trying to learn about
you know taoism and Buddhism and a
little bit more about Christianity and a
little bit more about Islam like like
simultaneously
um I ended up taking a course like in
university called like uh I ended up
taking like an intro to Christianity
course and a and of course about like
Jesus uh called Jesus of Nazareth
in an attempt to like
try and understand Christianity a little
bit more
but
in taking those courses I started to see
that
a lot of a lot of what I understood in
Christianity like
it was it was a very different a
different thing than what I was learning
at the time when I was taking those
courses like you know it was we took
like a historical approach to
understanding like you know the life of
Jesus or whatever and then like we went
into like the Bible and the Gospels
and and the gospels being like an
account of Jesus life
um and like
there's these
essentially like these contradictions
that like
that that like kind of took me away from
that that were that were different than
what I learned
so in trying to like understand
Christianity anymore I ended up
going in the opposite direction right
um
and I was still trying to learn about
Islam and
you know I I wanted to you know marry
this girl and you know that was like a
time ago
and
as the years are going by you know like
we're still looking to get married still
looking to get married but I I don't I
don't want to make that that step of
converting or I didn't want to make that
step of converting like for us to get
married you know like I wanted to I
wanted to make it because like I I
wanted to make it because I wanted it
for me you know and I know like I didn't
I didn't ever want
to mix those two things but how did she
feel about that did she kind of
encourage you more did she give you
pressure or was she like you know what I
want you to take your time and do it
like authentically
so
I would I would ask her a lot of
questions because I wanted like I was
trying to understand you know but you
know
she would like give me some answers or
at least direct me to someone to you
know somewhere or something or you know
to the Quran or someone who might know
the answers and like she would support
me but she never She always told me like
I'm not gonna like
I'm not gonna pressure you I'm not gonna
push you like I want you to to like come
to those answers you know
um so like she she never you know
obviously she wanted me to like uh you
know to you know become Muslim but she
never wanted to like push me to become
Muslim you know she wanted me to like
come to it like myself
um
and so
you know like obviously you know I we
had a lot of Muslim friends and
everything you know we're seeing a lot
of a lot of our friends you know getting
married you know year after year after
year you know you know when's your time
coming when's your time coming whatever
whatever
and I was
I I I I didn't know if I was if I was
going to be able to convert it would
like
I was I was delving into a lot of these
things I was trying to I was trying to
learn about
um you know Islam you know I would read
the Quran I would like I'd play it uh I
played like the English the English
translation on on YouTube or whatever
like
like I'd listen to it or listen to it
like prior to like sleeping and like
I would um
I read like The Surah al-baqarah and
like
yeah I'm seeing you know these things
that you know these verses about you
know the non-believer the non-believer
um
uh and like obviously like at the time
because I I felt like I was you know
agnostic or whatever I didn't believe
like they they hit me the wrong way you
know like I I thought
like you know oh I like I'm a good
person like how can I say this about you
know the non-believer about me like I'm
still good whatever whatever right and
then you know I'd read the the verses
that you know talk about like
um
about marriage and marriage of like a
non-believer and and marrying a believer
in how it's it's better to
um marry a a non-belief sorry it's
better to marry a Believer with you know
this trades than a non-believer with
like you know these traits or whatever
and so as I was reading those things
like
because I was I was holding I was
holding on to this this like atheism
you know
and
so
at a point I was like
I know like we we both really want to
like get married but
I don't know when like I don't know if
I'm gonna
if I'm gonna get there you know like
I I can't tell you that there's gonna be
uh
there's gonna be a point where I convert
because I don't know I've been trying
you know like I've been trying I've been
trying I've been trying I've been trying
to read the Quran I've been trying to
you know I've been watching so many of
these things I've been watching so many
of these debates I've really been trying
to learn I've been going to this person
going to that person but like it's not I
I can't I don't know there's something
that's stopping me from like accepting
it
and
so I I thought I'd you know we had this
like pretty emotional conversation that
like
I don't I didn't want her to like wait
for me anymore you know like I uh I'm
pretty much saying that like
obviously if if I'm a non-believer I
don't want you to
I I don't want you I don't want you to
be with me if that's what you know if
you if that's what you believe I and I
I'm not and I'm and I'm holding on to
you know my own um I'm holding on to
like my own uh beliefs as well and
so
so
that time you know this was this was
just last year that like we had this
conversation and like it was very like
it was very emotional because you know
we've been wanting to get married for so
long but
um I didn't know if it was gonna happen
if I was gonna make that next step
and so
I still continued to try you know I
still continue to like learn about Islam
I still kept reading the Quran
um and I was still simultaneously like
on this like
on this journey of trying to find Truth
by by learning about like all these
other religions or whatever
and um so
I was dealing as I said earlier you know
I was delving into these Eastern like
philosophical practices whatever and I
was meditating a lot and I was learning
you know a lot about like about ego and
this and this you know
this perspective you know this this
understanding of ego and like
um you know it it being like this like
filtration system or like this
processing system where like you know
you you you receive information and then
it gets processed and then you interpret
it in a certain way and how it like
affects certain things whatever
so I was I was learning a lot about ego
and I I was really I was really getting
into meditation and I was like I was I
was meditating a lot like I was like
really practicing it
um
and
as I was practicing meditation like
learning about ego I I started to
realize that
maybe the reason that I wasn't
understanding Islam is because of
my ego like maybe it's because of my
pride maybe it's because like you know
maybe that's the thing that like I need
to like
like kind of like take away in order for
me to like understand like the truths of
Islam
um and
so
as I was learning about Islam
about you know the prophet Muhammad and
like
um learning about like
these things I I started to
you know I believed in God because there
was a that logical uh that those logical
arguments that I started to understand
you know like the the intelligent design
argument and the and the first mover
argument whatever like those I I so I
started to believe in like you know a
first like I started to believe in God
in this way
and you know the more I started like you
know reading about you know the prophet
Muhammad and
um
you know I
I started to see that okay like
there's there's a message here you know
like
and so
I'm like okay wait this is like it's
kind of like the shahada like you know
these are these are these are the things
that like I
this is this is essentially what what
isn't what is the shahada right but
I kind of came to those
conclusions like in this manner and and
I felt like so I kind of did my shahada
but the the thing that was missing was
um
was that like that feeling like that
that conviction Within Me
and so earlier this year I did my
shahada but
privately you know
and so I I it was still
you know uh like
I was still not like sure like you know
like there's still like this doubt
Within Me
and so
I was understanding these these things
about
uh I was understanding these
philosophical practices or these these
things that I was learning in you know
these Eastern philosophical practices by
like practicing you know meditation
and so I thought maybe
I'm not understanding Islam because like
I'm not maybe I need to engage in in the
in the practice of Islam
and so I
I you know I started to to pray but I
haven't prayed in a decade because like
you know I I stopped believing in prayer
you know that with that whole experience
that I had you know I you know thinking
oh man I was trying to be patient for so
long whatever whatever
and I started I took myself away from
from religion like I haven't prayed like
in a decade
and so I was I I tried to start praying
but the way I was looking at it at the
time
it wasn't like it's kind of like I was
just going through emotions like I was
looking at praying almost like almost in
the same way that I was kind of looking
at meditation how you're just kind of
like you're putting yourself in this uh
in this position and then like you know
you go through these these motions
whatever whatever like the the intention
behind it kind of kind of wasn't there
but
as I was like you know learning to pray
you know I I learned to pray through
like you know these these YouTube videos
and
um
I guess I started I started to
understand like you know the words
and
as I started to pray that month
like things started to get like
things started to get worse
and I I wasn't like at the time I wasn't
attributing it to prayer
and I wasn't even making the connection
of like you know things getting worse I
wasn't making the connection of like
prayer and and these things getting
worse
but things around me started to get
worse
and I kind of hit a point where like my
back was against the wall
and I had to it's either like I run away
from the situation or like I like I
fight against it
and
you know I I started to like fight
against it and
you know
all these things started happening
all these things that I've been like
looking for for years all these there
are certain relationships that I've been
meaning to mend
um certain things that I've been like
wanting to happen for so long
they ended up starting to happen through
me kind of like fighting against in this
bad situation
um
like my back was against the wall and I
had to decide if I if I wanted to run
away or like you know go against it so
okay
so you know alhamdulillah like
as like as I
as things started getting worse and I
started to like
certain decisions that were helping
things in an attempt to like make things
better
all these doors just started opening
you know like
all these things just started happening
that like I've been
trying to make happen for so long or
I've been I've been wishing what
happened would happen in so long and so
despite all this bad stuff that was
going on
like there was so much like things so
much good that was coming out of it
um and at the time I wasn't attributing
it to prayer because I just I was just
looking at prayer as like you know just
like this means of or looking at prayer
I was just these motions but
then I started to like feel like
extremely
like confident
um in this like wild time
um and this was just you know last month
or two sorry not last month two two
three months ago
there was this like sense of like
like things are gonna be okay like and
this is like one of the worst things
that's like happening to me but at the
same time I haven't felt like so
like I haven't felt so
confident that like it's gonna be fine
like you know
and um
so
yeah I started I started to pray and
these things started happening
and then eventually I I started to like
feel this sense of like things just kind
of like fitting like like like things
are just starting to like like fill in
together
and
you know I had had a conversation with
my dad and like
uh
the the story of of Job in the Bible
kind of like came up
and
I I kind of remembered the story of Job
and
I haven't talked about the story
obviously in like so long
foreign I'll explain the significance of
that story in a second
but
that that same night I asked one of my
friends who was kind of in a similar
situation to me like you know like what
what did you do to like
like what what helped you understand
Islam more so he he directed me to um to
this uh this class at the Masjid our
local Masjid and so I went this one
night
and uh
you know the the Sheikh he was talking
about the you know the uh the story of
um
of barium
and
after that you know we prayed Isha and
I was I was new to prayer you know like
I I just understood like you know
the the motion of it but so I I prayed I
prayed Isha and then afterwards I wanted
to talk to the chick like
and essentially just ask some questions
like you know I was trying to understand
Islam a little bit more like what should
I do or like I I did my shahada like in
private but you know I've been trying to
understand Islam what should I do so
he's like you want to do your shahada
like you know you're at the Masjid I'm
like okay yeah sure
so that that same night like I did my
shahada at the Masjid and like
like it was uh
it was a weary
like beautiful experience for me like
it was so weird like I don't I didn't
know how to explain it like afterwards
you know it was it was nice
um you know all these brothers you know
afterwards came and they shook my hand
you know assalamualaikum and then like
you know everyone's just telling me
these things but they're telling me all
these things from the Quran that that
are hitting me like they're they're
hitting me like all these things from
the Quran that are just spot on with
what's going on right now and I'm like
how are you guys telling me this right
now like this is like you know and so
foreign
I went to go talk to a couple of my
friends right after and then I went to
go tell you know
um
I went to go tell that girl that I
mentioned
and you know alhamdulillah like
everything was so good
and uh so I went to sleep that night
and I had like the most the most Vivid
dream like one of the most like vivid
dreams that I've ever like had and it
was
uh it was this like so I was driving
you know the 403 are you guys you're in
there right yeah I was driving
um
403 or to the highway essentially and I
was taking the ramp to the highway to
get onto the highway
and if you like if if anyone who knows
me like they know how much like I love
driving like I like driving is something
that like I I love doing like I'll I'll
drive in in times of like you know it's
just something that I felt was
therapeutic for me so I drive all the
time and it's something that I felt like
completely cool you're even in the car
now
[Music]
but uh but yeah so
um
driving and I was driving down
um this ramp
and
as I was driving down the ramp in my
dream I ended up getting tired and I
ended up closing my eyes for a second
and in that Split Second I ended up like
getting it I ended up like falling off
the track and going into a ditch
foreign
but so the girl that I mentioned she was
driving in front of me
and she noticed that I fell
and so she pulled over him and she
called someone
and then that person but I didn't see
their face but that person
essentially helped me get me and my car
out of the ditch
and I um
I remember getting out of the ditch in
my dream and just being angry like
like man like how did I how did I let
myself like get tired you know like how
did I let myself like just
you know I thought I had so much control
um you know of this of this car like I
I'm so confident in my driving and I
somehow managed to like let myself get
tired and fall
into this ditch and
I was I don't know why I was such a I
mean I I guess I kind of understand it
at the moment but when I woke up I'm
like why was that dream so like like
Vivid like it was one there's only a
couple dreams that I've ever had in my
life that have been so like
so clear
and it was such a clear dream
and I was trying to think like like why
was I driving and why was this and and
like why was she there and stuff like
that and like the only thing that I
could really like
understand of it the way or the way I
could interpret it was like
you know
I was driving and you know thinking like
I had control over everything
and
I ended up you know slipping
and it kind of resonated with like what
was going on in my life at the time
because like
when I
decided to become like or when I when I
took myself away from religion
it obviously allowed for my um my
boundaries to be kind of like
looser you know like I started to like
I guess like rationalize things that
like I wouldn't before you know like uh
you know this is okay to do or like you
know it's fine if I do this because you
know I don't I don't believe in you know
that anymore or whatever right
so
but in my dream yeah like I was I was
driving and I I kind of like managed to
lose control and and I fell into this
ditch
and like you know the person who brought
me out of the ditch or the person who
helped me get out of the ditch was her
you know like she
she called for someone to help me get
out and
I was so like kind of like like blown by
this dream
and um
I I started to like understand that like
man no matter how much I may feel like
I'm like in control or something like I
I really want to be in control over this
thing
like I'm
I'm subordinate to something you know
like I'm it wasn't me who who like I
didn't tell myself to get tired like I
got tired like there's something that
I I'm not the highest thing you know
like
okay
something else
allowed for that to happen you know
and
so
yeah I uh I woke up the next morning and
like
I wanted to write down this dream so I I
was like typing into my uh I was writing
it out essentially
and
I was writing it out and
I had something playing
um I had like this um
this piano
this piano playing while I was writing
and um there's like a video that was
attached to that to that
song or whatever
and that in the video it was just in the
video it's just a visual of like these
things kind of
like branching out it's just it's like a
visual of all these all these branches
and like
certain things happening and
I just started like crying like
it was like um I don't know there was
something about like you know those
those branches that were happening just
seeing them and
I just started like bawling like
everything just started to fit at that
moment like
like all these everything just started
to make sense for some reason like it
was it was like the biggest like Eureka
moment that I've ever had like it was it
was like you know like you know when
you're in math class and like you know
you're learning you're learning learning
and like nothing really makes sense and
then eventually like oh like this is
this is it like oh like I understand
like
it was this like Giant like moment of
like understanding
and um
like like all these queries and all
these all these questions and all these
things that I've been questioning like
the one piece that like was missing like
the one thing that was missing in order
for like all these things to be answered
like was Allah like like that was the
missing that was missing you know like
that was the one missing thing that was
the thing that I was like
rejecting all this time
to find the truth like it was like it
was kind of always there you know it was
and so
okay like
um I uh
I don't know I just started crying I
started crying and crying and crying and
I haven't cried that much like
whatever I don't think I've ever cried
that much like I was just bawling my
eyes out
but it wasn't like sadness it was like
it was like Beauty it was like I
couldn't I couldn't stop seeing things
so like beautiful like like
it was so weird I didn't know how to
explain it
and
you know
I mean the like the only thing the only
like feeling I could relate it to is
something that like you know you know
stuff for a lot like something I've done
prior that wasn't natural you know like
and and this was completely just
unnatural experiences like literally the
the highest point of like emotion that
I've ever experienced in my life
and
I didn't know how to explain it I just
kept I kept crying I kept crying I kept
crying I even went to the I even like
you know I took a second and I was going
to the gym and I wanted to go shoot
around or whatever and like literally
I'm in the gym
I start crying and I'm like bro I gotta
relax you know I go to the treadmill
I started tearing up like you know this
is upon a lot like you know I don't I I
couldn't stop like that entire week the
entire week was just like just tears of
like
just like
beautiful like everything was just so
beautiful
but um
yeah so
that was the day after I did my shahada
and uh
so
now things start to get interesting and
like a lot of things start to happen
that I like I couldn't explain
and
you know it's almost like I I was trying
to like ground myself in you know in
logic and ground myself in in science in
order to understand all these things and
it's as if like Allah was telling me
like
okay you wanna you wanna ground yourself
in like complete logic let me break that
for you let me show you like
the so all these things start to happen
that like are not making sense to me but
I can't deny it
um
so
a week before I um a week before I did
my shahada
I I was trying to go on this little like
dopamine detox or whatever I deleted use
I deleted YouTube off my phone I deleted
Instagram off my phone you know I was
trying to focus on like you know those
things that were happening that I was
saying that like you know we're kind of
tough
foreign
comes to mind like okay like I'm gonna
re-download these things like I'm gonna
re-download YouTube and I'm gonna
re-download Instagram
but I'm not gonna do it like with the
intention of just mindlessly scrolling
or whatever just going through these
videos or whatever whatever like I'm
gonna do it with the intention of trying
to connect
and so that thought came to my mind
um inshallah and like
so I re-download YouTube
like two nights after I did my shadow
and uh
I redownload YouTube and the very very
first thing on my because I was on my
phone so the very first thing on my
YouTube recommended is Young Dom
converts from Christianity to Islam
and I'm like subhanallah you guys you
guys end up posting a video
of this guy we you know we got the same
skin complexion this other guy named
Dominic
converts from his converts from
Christianity to Islam
and I'm like what it like what are the
what are the odds like what are the
chances right
you know like
wow so I started to watch the video and
you know that guy Dominic and he's
talking and you guys asked him like yo
when did you convert and he's like two
days ago I'm like I converted two days
ago I'm like what
foreign
as much like you know I was a part of me
was like
trying to understand or kind of like
I was trying to frame it
and like probability like what is the
probability of this happening like
nothing happens in coincidence bro
and the Hawaii I believe like I
understand that in entirety
like
so
that happened and I was trying to frame
it in probability and I was trying to
like you know think like what are the
odds what are the odds like
and no matter how I tried to frame it
it it blew it blew up my logic like
and um
and that point like my like my mind like
my
I couldn't I had to stop like the
whatever what was in me that was trying
to like
like deny
just
just you know
I like like as if Allah was telling me
like you know like you've been pushing
me away for so long like I'm here like
like
I don't know man like yeah it was it was
such a it was such a
mind-blowing experience for me
and then just after that
more and more and more and more and more
um you know like
I mentioned that like I I had a
conversation about my dad about the
story of Job in the Bible
and uh I haven't heard about that story
in so long
and um
and then uh
one of my brothers at the Masjid he
he's like yo are you uh are you going to
that event uh this uh in a couple weeks
or in two weeks I'm like what event he's
like um uh Omar Suleiman he's he's
coming to talk about uh you know the
prophet Ayub Islam and um I'm like oh
who's who's that like I was trying to
understand like who's that profit in the
Bible and then well I think in the Bible
it's a job
and I'm like huh like what you know like
the story of Job became so
experience in my life at this time and
then you're telling me that like you
know Omar Suleiman is coming to like
speak about you know the prophet Ayub
who was you know in Christianity's job
and
so yeah all these all these things just
started happening
um that like
I it's not like I could I
it kind of just broke all that all that
for me like
trying to
think it's coincidence whatever whatever
like and then I started to understand
like
you know
um
I think you guys had a you guys had a uh
a video or live stream like a while ago
or a couple weeks ago or whatever and I
was trying to reconcile like
this uh this understanding of like you
know determinism and free will
and I think you guys like kind of like
gave me the answer and you guys um
they're directing me to uh for Us's
hobby or sorry for us the hobby right
and how he explains it and like it all
just started to like piece together so
perfectly like
like everything just started to like
like fit so perfectly and then I I
started to understand like like the
truth like
like the completeness
you know
um
then yeah since then like
that was two months ago and like you
know my journey in Islam
you know alhamdulillah you know so
since then you know since then like just
um
you know just alhamdulillah like every
day and you know just every day
alhamdulillah you know so
um yeah this is beautiful
man yeah did you end up uh getting
married
so inshallah like
for us to you know to like complete that
marriage you know they're they're
happening yeah so it's very very very
very very soon like inshallah like you
know like you know we've been wanting to
get married for so long and you know
like we
um and you know this was kind of one of
the things at least I was like you know
so yeah yeah like very like very very
soon like inshallah like we're gonna
complete that last step and yeah
I'm the love bro we got some questions
here uh for you let's let's see if you
want to answer some of them so someone
asked who is the most influential Muslim
person in your decision to convert to
Islam
the most influential Muslim person like
around me
um
hmm
you know it's funny because I I want to
say that she was you know but she
it's not like she she like told me much
but like she she supported me and like
directed me to certain things you know
and
um
yeah and the Sheikh the Masjid the local
Masjid like
him too I guess you know like the way he
speaks
um
you know masha'allah like
he he spoke a lot of things that like
were just hitting me and hitting me and
hitting me just one after the other
after the other was it was it one of the
major uh one of the major masjids in the
city that we were talking about
yes yeah I know what you're talking
about bro yeah
he speaks in a way where it's he did a
couple of my friends in the car as well
and when he speaks it like it resonates
it's not just empty words hitting you
you know yeah yeah yeah
we got a we got a weird question bro
from this guy named a lot Thomas
question for fight and Angel could I
still convert even if my name is Allah I
was born with that name I didn't choose
it should I just go to a Masjid near me
and talk to someone my grandfather was
in a Nation of Islam that's how I was
given that name
I'm changing my name to Abdullah but who
do I talk to before am I allowed in a
much bro I'm gonna be honest with you
like none of us are Scholars here so we
can't give you like a like a fatwa like
a ruling like what to do but there
should be nothing holding you back from
Islam bro from accepting it yeah so but
I will say the name Allah isn't a name
that we should name our kids so you I'm
pretty sure you gotta change your name
bro
um but definitely accept Islam uh sooner
than later
um and yeah
man but yeah it's um
no I don't know I was gonna say
something but then this the brother's
question got me there
uh but yeah I know what you said bro
like don't don't make any excuse man
just go in the Masjid and become Muslim
uh you can just give yourself the
nickname if you want to go like my name
is Ong head but like a lot of Muslims
anytime I go into a Masjid and like I
just introduce myself as Malik because
that's that's like the the way that you
say you would say my name in Arabic so
then it's just kind of kind of took took
into effect so it is what it is like do
you want to change it legally that's up
to you I mean I'm
I think if you become Muslim you
probably would change it legally at some
point
but you know like just just go in there
you know don't don't wait at all
And in regards to you bro
now that'll make it easy for you and
everything that you're doing right now I
mean I think bro I said this before and
I just think it's crazy that it's it's
always when
we reach those like Rock Bottom moments
that's when we're Guided by Allah yeah
yeah I was uh I was thinking about this
the other day and like how you know like
like when you have like a large cut
and like all your attention is just on
that cut you know if it's painful like
and it hurts like your attention is just
brought to that cut
and and sometimes you know that that cut
being open can be like
it's it's like it's like a calling for
something it's like you know like like
there's something going on here there's
something that needs to be done about it
and um
sometimes something else can come and
you get an infection and like you know
if that's like sometimes shaytan will
like whisper some things and like
we'll fill that cut but not in a good
way and but when that cut is open like
you know the body is what I'm from I
understand like you need to fill that
with like
you could fill that with Allah you know
you need to fill that with like the
Quran like
and so yeah yeah
no but I feel you 100 man I just think
it's crazy that like every single River
bro we've all hit Like a Rock Bottom
moment even born Muslims who came back
to the dean and I really started
practicing it's it's usually because
they hit like some kind of rock bottom
moment in their life yeah and it it goes
to this like this saying that I've heard
where it's like it's it's basically only
in the dark that the light shines
brightest yeah
that's crazy bro that's crazy and you
saying your dream bro isn't it crazy how
like the clearest dreams are the ones
that usually have like the clearest
message yeah to us the clear sign right
yeah and um oh man bro I remember like a
few years before I became Muslim
obviously this is when I was in that
stage that you were talking about where
you were like looking at all these
different religions trying to like
understand
make sense of it all
I had this dream I was in like a train
station
and I remember there was a shooter that
came in and he was like pop up he's just
getting everyone left and right and at
one point I'm on the ground and like I
think I'm all right and I'm trying to
kind of like inch away but as I'm
inching away like my body's like feeling
like cold and colder and I'm like oh
damn like is this really it like is this
really the end
and I remember like in that moment in
the dream like I like my spirit had left
my body
and I'm over here like trying to like go
to people that I know like trying to
talk to them but they can't hear me they
can't see me so I'm like damn I can't
believe this is it I can't believe this
is the end and like like I see I see
these like old friends of mine that I
had and I'm like trying to talk to them
and they they can't even see me I'm like
damn but then my dream I was like crying
because like I'm just thinking to myself
like
oh man I couldn't even tell the people
that I was closest to like how much I
love them
and it's like I didn't even get to like
really do what I wanted to do in life I
didn't even get to figure out like what
would my purpose here in this world was
and then in the dream I ended up finding
like
I don't know if it was a uh this woman
or if it was my mom I can't recall it's
been years since I had the dream but I
remember like I went to this woman in
specific whether it was a mom or whether
it was a different woman cannot recall
but they had said oh I was I was talking
to them and they could hear me they
could basically hear me they couldn't
see me but they could hear me and I was
like begging them like almost like
screaming like crying like telling them
like would I do what I do and they were
like you need to find the PATH and I was
like what's the path they're like you
know and not and like in the moment like
the it was basically like it was
referring to the holy text
like the you know like the Bible the
Quran the Torah and stuff like that and
I'm like I'm basically asking which one
which one and like the the woman was
basically saying like you already know
which one
and like I never really understood that
dream but like
obviously in retrospect just like it all
these things happen for a reason and
it's all like remember things don't
happen when we want it to happen things
happen when Allah wants it to happen so
it's like Allah does everything
perfectly and then he reveals things in
a way where it's just like he just
connects all the pieces perfectly to
where when it hits it hits you hard
yeah yeah
that's deep man we definitely got to
bring you back for part two inshallah
I wanna before we wrap it up though um
because we do gotta end the stream soon
do you have any questions anything
you're kind of struggling with anything
you wanna you wanna get out there
um or do you have anything you want to
share the things that made your journey
easy
um
yeah
you know this journey has been so easy
for me I mean like it's been easy for me
like with the help of like a lot of a
lot of the brothers from the Masjid you
know a lot of like you know these new
brothers that I've like come across
you know like me like learning Islam and
me like surrounding myself with like you
know a lot of these people that either
they
they can tell me something or they can
refer to someone who knows something you
know yeah
they'll tell me something and they'll
refer to the Quran or they'll you know
they'll refer to me they'll refer me to
you know who who knows or or a scholar
or someone and so like you know this
this journey of me like learning like
like this journey of me like trying to
understand like knowledge and trying to
understand like truth
and trying to find knowledge like it's
it's been made easier by a lot of uh you
know the guys around me a lot of the
brothers around me and so alhamdulillah
I guess uh
that's uh what I'll say
let me make it easy for you allow you to
get married to that girl if she's the
best one and the right one for you and
vice versa and put Baraka in your
marriage and what a good example bro
what a good role model for all the
people that are kind of on edge you know
recently after Andrew take converted a
lot of men have been like you know what
I've been kind of I've been needing this
push you know what I mean I don't know
how to accept Islam I really want to but
there's this block and you were talking
about this this block something that was
just there you know and that block Allah
might remove that block in one way for
someone and another way for another
person but may Allah use this video this
stream as a means to facilitate you know
removing that block and a lot of people
that are kind of on the edge on the
fence I mean I mean
oh yeah well thank you guys you know for
uh for having me and everything and
inshallah that's that's what it does you
know that's what this video does though
come through and meet you sometime if
not brought me Allah reunited
and uh you know definitely film that bro
inshallah we can meet uh in this life or
if not this life then in the next
and so on and with that being said bro
from now on every time we have a guest
they have to end it off with a Dua bro
so floor is yours bro we
I told you this in the beginning right
no I didn't I'm just I don't know
you know what instead you can you can
you can close off with just telling the
viewers what your favorite Surah in the
Quran is you don't have to recite it
just if you have a favorite soda or one
that sticks out which one would it be
um
uh
um
or you know like this you know that I
guess they're being what I what I've
been saying every single day and all you
know all my prayers and everything so
um it was a wonderful stream so glad
that we did this inshallah we do it
again
um and guys inshallah stay tuned for our
future upcoming videos with brother Dam
inshallah we'll bring them back in a few
months or whatever when he's a little
bit more on his journey he has a little
bit more wisdom Insha'Allah but I think
today was phenomenal bro so we thank you
for that and uh to close off salaam
alaikum